sometimes the act of pushing other
distractions away
can help us to focus hi there steve
kaufman here
today i want to talk about
focus how do we stay focused in language
learning
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe
click on the bell click on the bell for
notifications if you follow me on
spotify or apple podcast or elsewhere
please leave a review
focus
i get this question all the time people
say they lose focus
so how do we how do we get focused how
do we stay focused
um
it just turns out that in my persian
learning
uh we were able to get permission to use
some podcasts by a fellow called b-plus
who
does a sort of farsi persian language uh
summaries of very popular self-help
books
so he did one on
uh deep learning a deep work core amig
deep work and one on focus tamarkos
uh and so i went back to have a look at
those i
wanted to see if there was something
there and i'd gone through them in
persian and didn't find them that
interesting actually and so but then i
went back and looked at them again to
look at them again to see if i could
learn anything relevant
uh right away i was more focused because
i was interested in in the subject to
see if there was anything there that
would be helpful in addressing this
whole issue of focus
there wasn't because like so many of
these self-help books it's just a lot of
common sense stuff packaged together in
in a new format you know we need to
concentrate we need to focus
and you know taking some examples of
people in history who would isolate
themselves
for two weeks at a time bill gates would
go off to his cottage or or
jung the famous psychologist or
psychiatrist to have a chalet in
switzerland or something and
and certainly i remember
[Music]
you know there are people in history uh
who was it who had his tower that
montagne who wrote essays in french he
had his tower there somewhere down in
the southwest of france where he would
go and he would be isolated and
obviously if we can isolate ourselves
that helps us concentrate but most
people who are learning languages they
can't take two weeks off to go off
somewhere
if they have two weeks they're probably
better off to go to the country where
the language is spoken
so how do we focus in our language
learning
um
some sort and and also and this comes up
in both these books and it's something
we're well aware of
the modern sort of internet information
age where we have access to
information we have access to so much
language content for example we have
access to
you know grammar grammatical
explanations at the you know click of a
google
uh you know uh keystroke
um
and we have also access to to an
audience for anything we want to do like
right now i'm talking to people i i
don't know and
so this is a new world and there's good
and there's bad and the good is that we
can access so many things and we can
get our message to so many people and we
can learn so many things quickly if i if
i'm doing something in persian and they
refer to a certain dynasty in the
history of persia and then i can go and
click wikipedia and and read it in
english which is easier for me to
understand then i go back and so there
are all these distractions so what do we
do
first of all
one very surprising thing is
i find that one of the best places for
me to focus is in an airplane where
there's noise there's people but i'm
stuck there
so
in a way all of the noise and the
possible distractions are not
distractions i find that i'm able to do
a lot of reading and a lot of study on
an airplane
uh we had a programmer at link
who did his best work he we have a sort
of what we call a sky train which is our
public transit system which travels
around above ground it's not underground
and he would go on the sky train with
all of the distractions that were there
and he found himself better able to
concentrate and come up with solutions
in terms of his programming so it's not
obvious and i have said before that if i
sit down to listen to something just to
listen to something i easily lose my
focus whereas if i'm doing the dishes or
in the car i have some other activity
and i'm better able to focus i know
there are people who can focus better in
a in in a cafe
with all the distractions in the other
people than they can can at home where
they're on their own so sometimes the
act of pushing other distractions away
can help us to focus i think everyone
has to find their own you know most you
know which environment is more most
conducive to focus
i think having a time of the day
is good so my listening is not so much a
focused activity i i listen i sometimes
focus sometimes don't focus i don't
think it's a problem it's it's free
learning because it's learning that
happens while i'm doing something else
so i'm not attempting to to learn
anything during that period i just know
that it's beneficial to be listening to
whatever it is i'm listening to but i
try to have a certain period of time and
because i'm retired it can be in the
afternoon i used to do it before going
to sleep but that's a bit distracting
and i don't think it's good for the
brain to be trying very hard to learn
things just before going to bed and and
i think there is perhaps some truth in
the fact that because i do a lot of my
learning on the ipad that having that
electronic those signals coming at you
is probably not good for your sleep so
if i am going to study say egyptian
arabic or something i will have i have a
textbook so or a book but a textbook and
so i will look at the book before going
to sleep but i don't i don't want to use
my ipad before going to and going to
sleep but for some people that could be
a period of time where they are able to
focus and concentrate
i have said that with my listening which
i do first thing in the morning that's
another part of my routine i don't worry
about my focus
whatever i'm able to pick up from my
listening is good and i'll either be
listening to my mini story for the 35th
time or i'll be listening to
a news podcast and and
getting something from that i don't
worry about my focus there
this idea of of distractions obviously
if we are still working and we're
interrupted and we're checking our email
or checking our uh you know messages
obviously it's better to to do that you
know save it until the end of the hour
or save it but these are things that so
many people have written about that you
can't be constantly checking your
twitter feed constantly checking your
emails or your messages you're better
off to save that for a period of time do
it in a you know in a sort of a batch
and then
get back so that you're learning your
language learning is
uh you know a batch process you're
spending time with your language and
then the other duties that you have then
they occur at a certain time now i'm not
saying anything there that
hundreds of other people haven't said
not everyone can do that and obviously
it's very tempting
to
especially okay the olympic games
you know whatever your country is how
did we do
in the middle of your studying because
you you can access it you go and do it
so
you know we can say don't do that and
some people are going to do it
nevertheless part of it is how
genuinely motivating
is whatever you're reading or listening
to
uh how
you know committed are you to the task
at hand if you're only casually
committed to the task you'll be more
easily
um you know distracted
if if say you were
you know your life depended upon
learning something you would be totally
motivated to learn that you would stay
on the task
uh if uh you're very interested in some
aspect of japanese anime or whatever it
might be or or
persian history then yeah i'm going to
stay on task if it's not interesting
then i won't stay on task so focus is
also a function
of how relevant how interesting how
compelling whatever content you have
is
now
when you're speaking of course i don't
think focus is so much of an issue
because you're involved in a
conversation say with your tutor your
tutor is going to ask you questions
you're going to have to respond to the
questions so focus there is not so much
of an issue focus
becomes a bigger issue when you're
involved in what
could be considered passive activities
like listening and reading
and your mind wanders
and the in today's day and age in the
inner internet age it's easy to be
distracted and allow your mind to wander
so
uh
you know all i can say really is in my
own case i am distracted
i think to some extent
it's a it's a negative that goes with
all of the other advantages that the
internet age provides us so i accept
that and i think i beat off the the
impulse to go and
check uh check up on my email or my
twitter feed
as best i can and sometimes i succumb
but
you know at the end of the day there's
still a lot of focused learning that
takes place and i think we don't need to
be perfectionists when it comes to focus
and just try our best to focus as best
we can using whatever methods work best
with our lifestyle so that's really all
i have to say on the subject of focus
so i hope that was useful bye for now